as russia's war drags out in ukraine to
its west it's causing ripple effects in
central asia to its south the war has
made kazakhstan which is russia's
largest ally in the region increasingly
nervous and it has opened a door for
closer cooperation with the west here's
why
first let's take a closer look at the
map
kazakhstan borders the caspian sea but
since it doesn't have access to an ocean
it's considered the largest landlocked
country in the world in the neighborhood
are countries like russia
china turkey and iran over here is
western europe
that puts kazakhstan at the heart of
critical trade routes but it's also made
its economy heavily dependent on its
powerful neighbors the largest among
them is russia the former soviet sister
states shared this border which is
nearly 5 000 miles long that is the
second largest frontier in the world
after the u.s canada border and similar
to ukraine kazakhstan has a large ethnic
russian population about 22 percent and
many of them live along this northern
border
for years russian nationalists have
claimed that some of this land should
belong to russia similar to how they
perceive parts of ukraine that sentiment
has even been echoed by president
vladimir putin who said this about
kazakhstan's former leader in 2014
that sounds a lot like what putin has
been saying about ukraine and while that
kind of rhetoric was brushed off in the
past the invasion of ukraine has been a
wake-up call
to get a better sense of how the country
is responding i called my colleague evan
gershkovic who's been reporting from the
region they are worried extremely
worried about
what i think everybody has seen as an
increasingly erratic government in
moscow he says the country's oil
industry is a good example kazakhstan is
among the world's top oil producers and
take a look at its gdp growth you can
see that it tends to rise and fall along
with global oil prices the economy is
heavily reliant on oil sales
it has benefited from soaring oil prices
fueled by the war in ukraine and its oil
is seen as increasingly important to
europe which has begun to wean itself
off of russian fossil fuels but take a
look at this kazakhstan relies on this
caspian pipeline that runs through
russia to transport 80 percent of its
oil that reliance is a key vulnerability
according to researchers i talked to at
fitch ratings
russia has ordered the pipeline closed
twice in recent months the second time
came after kazakhstan's president kasim
jomar tokayev shared a stage with putin
and said that kazakhstan would not
recognize the breakaway republics of
luhansk and donetsk in ukraine
russia blamed alleged environmental
violations for the shutdown not those
comments but it rattled officials and
takayev ordered oil companies to explore
other ways to export the country's oil
it's clear that kazakhstan is freaked
out by this russia is still trying to
show who's in charge okay so oil is a
big deal but trade is another way that
kazakhstan has been impacted by the war
it has promised to enforce western
sanctions against russia a stance that
has anchored some in moscow but could
help kazakhstan become a critical trade
hub its ports on the caspian sea have
seen a surge in container shipments
compared to last year and the war has
drawn more attention to this so-called
middle corridor in the current war
situation it's the one main way to get
goods from china to europe that's not by
sea and so kazakhstan is trying to take
advantage of that the war in ukraine has
also changed how kazakhstan is thinking
about its security
in january when violent anti-government
protests broke out in kazakhstan tokyo
called in russian troops to help restore
order but now that russia has invaded a
former soviet state and neighbor
officials are rethinking their strategy
not only has the country boosted its
defense spending it has agreed to
strengthen military cooperation with
china according to china's ministry of
defense
and it also struck a deal with turkey a
nato member to jointly produce attack
drones kazakhstan has also had visitors
from the u.s including a top u.s
commander since the invasion u.s
diplomats have gone to central asia
multiple times so what we're seeing is
not necessarily this massive
geopolitical realignment but sort of
kazakhstan and the rest of central asia
hedging its
bets and the us seeing an opportunity
one central asia researcher told the
journal that the kremlin isn't troubled
just yet but if the government in
kazakhstan turns hostile it would be
seen as an even greater threat to russia
than ukraine since the countries share
such a long border kazakhstan's economy
isn't the only one reliant on russia
check out this video to learn more about
how europe could be impacted by a
natural gas war with moscow i'll see you
next time